Okay, it's time for hatred.
Get Mail if you have never heard hatred at
mail before.
I get a lot of hate mail.
Some of that hate mail is almost poetic in
nature in some way, shape or form.
Uh, takes a little bit of imagination.
I understand.
And we take that hate mail and a professional
voiceover artist narrates it for us.
Here's a quick reminder about hatred.
Mail.
We're so outright EADS wrong.
Hey, triaged written by patriots who hate
David Pacman because America and because freedom.
Okay.
Uh, this week's hatred mail, um, the entire
thing is what I call a mute point.
Not a moot point.
It's a mute point.
Take a listen to this
hashtag fake news.
Pacman is lying and distorting the facts.
This is a mute point already settled by legal
experts.
Now it's just getting pacman's stupid.
The Russian dossier is not illegal.
Hitler, he paid a former British agent who
paid Russians for Info and got cheated by
being fed bogus, unfitted crap and return.
Hillary asked for the Info and paid for it
first because if Trump proves false, it could
hurt trust in Hillary's campaign, but it's
still no illegal.
It was unsolicited.
Just,
yeah, like a many hatred.
Males, you know, sometimes there are lots
of specific reactions that I have.
I could address the use of the word Hitler
[inaudible].
That's when I've seen floating around.
That's cute.
But honestly, I think my entire analysis would
simply be mute.
So I will only say that the best way to send
a middle finger salute to the hatred hits
and say, no, no, no, you're wrong.
And the left is right is to sign up for a
membership using the coupon code hatred 40
that saves you 40% off of your membership
and the hatred, it's just cry.
They immediately start bawling when people
use that coupon code because it shows them
that they are failing.
They are failing to take down the David Pakman
show.